back to co-pilot today you know him from
rupaul's drag race olive's favorite show
and he's a dear friend of the show and
the life of every party ross matthews
yes
everybody it is election day i do it's
finally here so exciting i live for it
i'm so excited
i i really really am okay so let's check
out some election headlines from across
the country
first up oh by the way friend of the
show d nice he's spinning
all day on instagram live djing
until the poll is closed yeah that's a
good stress relief if you need to just
go and like rock out
well and if the quarantine taught us
anything is that he's a great leader
exactly so check that out okay and if
you're headed out to the polls today
usa today reports that uber and lyft
want to help
lyft is offering 50 off your ride to any
poll location or ballot dropbox
with the code 2020 vote and uber is
offering offering 50
off round trip to the polls when you use
poll finder feature in their app
that is like the best news ever there's
no excuse not to get out there and vote
now right
i know good for them hey and after you
vote you can proudly wear that i voted
sticker which is like the best i've seen
on your instagram yeah and then you can
head out for some
freebies yeah we found where you can
snag some free snacks
today just for voting it's election day
food news
there she is sammy i love when you say
num nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom it's
sammy soles
she's her voice all right listen you
really can get free stuff just for
voting
how i'm going to tell you right now at
boston market voters get a free slider
today yeah how about krispy kreme
you vote you get a free glazed donut
today
all right at wawa you get a free coffee
so your donut can do the dip
how about that yes we at chili's which
is one of my favorites i've ever had the
skillet queso dip i got my baby okay
well you can get a president a margarita
for five dollars and a free
commemorative chili sticker so that's
fun and at shake shack you get free
fries when you get a burger
don't mind if i do it is a free country
why not enjoy
a free donut i love this
this is so fun and in more voting news
tacoma park maryland people as young as
16 can legally vote
in local elections 16. i know yeah
i don't know how i feel about it well
it's interesting because the washington
report post reports that
more cities are looking to lower the
voting age
and currently in 18 states and
washington dc
17 year olds can vote in primaries
and special elections if they're going
to be 18 by the general election
so i did i really thought about this
ross i thought about myself
at 16. yeah that's where i went right
away well and i was like oh god was i
responsible not really but i also grew
up fast
so i was sort of like born 10 i don't
know but here's what i also came to the
conclusion of what
i was a working girl and if you are
16 or 17 and you have a job you have to
pay taxes yes
so my thought is if you pay taxes you
should be able to vote
yeah we went to the same place because
okay you were in movies at 16. i was
working at mcdonald's at 16 but we were
both paying taxes
exactly now that being said i thought
about who i was at 16. and i think if
you're to vote you should be
like socially aware of the issues at 16
i would have cast my vote for ginger
spice
so i think i think maybe wait a couple
years until you're aware of what it
means what taxes mean to a middle-class
family what it means to have health care
and all right can you really
process that at 16. you know i will say
this when we were growing up there was
no social media
and i was not as conscientious about my
civic duties or the world at large
um and i traveled the world like i was
worldly
but i wasn't newsy and so i do think
that
this generation is much more equipped
um and i do think they become much more
equipped
um with each generation at grasping
their world around them so i do have a
lot of faith you know what i'll co-stamp
that
okay props to the young kids yeah yep
and whether you're 16 or not you can
join americans voting voting in every
corner of this country today and you
will be shocked where you actually can
vote take a look
lifeguard stations people are voting i
love this
swimming pools right hair salons get a
new do
in a new country are you ready for this
one num num num
taquerias okay yes please that's what
i'm talking about
yeah okay uh what about this a
harley-davidson
showroom people are voting there from
vroom
i love this one laundry mat yeah well we
want a clean election drew we do and
that's why people
people are voting everywhere that's
right and wherever you go
um get there and make your voice heard